la vaccination comme arme pour lutter
contre la propagation du variant delta
et tenter d'endiguer cette quatrième
vague si elle progresse en france si la
demande est forte
l'offre n'est pas toujours au rendez
vous et les doses de vaccin en manque
parfois en particulier dans les zones
rurales
reportage dans les côtes d'armor de
serial bout et qui est aujourd'hui
demory depuis les annonces des manuels
macron il ya deux semaines de plus en
plus de français demande à se faire
vacciner contre le coc vie 19 mai dans
cet établissement regroupant plusieurs
professionnels de santé à saint-alban
dans les côtes d'armor
les doses de vaccin manquent à l'appel
face au report de sa première injection
ou ce patient oscille entre
incompréhension et interrogations
j'arrive j'avais rendez vous à 15h 15
rendez vous qui était programmé depuis
une quinzaine de jours
et là j'apprends arrivés sur place que
il ya plus de doses je n'ai plus de
doses pour me faire vacciner quoi et
c'est un petit peu contradictoire on
nous demande de faire un donc l'effort
de la de se faire vacciner le plus vite
possible et on s'aperçoit que ben il
n'ya pas les doses nécessaires pour
vacciner ceux qui veulent le faire quoi
si la vaccination est possible dans les
cabinets d'infirmiers libéraux les
quantités de serre sommes mises à leur
disposition sont parfois insuffisantes
une situation dénoncée par les patients
de cette maison de santé aux rives et 7
cette étape 2
de cette pandémie en fait on devrait pas
avoir le droit de manquer dos quoi on
nous fait la promo mais la pression pour
se faire vacciner
et d'un autre côté il n'y a pas assez
12la la base je voulais inscrire tout le
monde enfin voilà un point de rendez
vous pour tout le monde et on n'a pas pu
parce que justement ils n'ont pas les
doses et même sur les sites internet
il n'y a pas de place à part rennes qui
est à une heure de route face à la
hausse spectaculaire des prises de
rendez vous depuis les annonces du chef
de l'état notamment sur le pass annie
taire certains infirmiers libéraux ne
parviennent pas à se faire livrer
suffisamment de doses de vaccins thénot
deux flacons de bonheur doc on a réussi
à voir très difficilement ce flacon là
il est un médecin
ce flacon là il est un pharmacien mais
nous nous n'avons pas reçu nos doses de
vaccin pour que nous avons commandé il
ya maintenant treize jours fabien soro a
décidé de lancer un appel aux autorités
depuis le début de la crise ça a été ça
en fait il ya les annonces et après ce
qui se passe sur le terrain nous on veut
des doses
on nous dit qu'il y à des doses mais sur
le terrain en fait on a de grosses
difficultés à s'approvisionner
les professionnels de santé ne sont pas
les seuls à vouloir augmenter la cadence
pierre-alexis blévin maire de pléneuf
val andré a souhaité mettre en place un
centre de vaccination éphémère dans deux
de ces espaces municipaux dont un au
casino pour cela les deals dont la
population passe de 4500 habitants à
plus de 30000 durant l'été a adressé un
courrier au préfet des côtes d'armor
une lettre qui n'a toujours pas reçu de
réponse d'un côté on nous dit il faut
vacciner plus et d'un autre côté quand
on dit on veut vous donner les moyens
pour pouvoir vous permettre de vacciner
plus pas cons et qu'on ait pas de
réponse les services de l'état sont
conscients que on a des risques de
d'épidémie d'augmentation de l'épidémie
et pour autant ben on nous répond pas et
on ne nous aide pas à
à renforcer en tous les cas la
vaccination sur les sur les territoires
touristiques qui aujourd'hui sont ont
explosé avec avec la saison estivale
de son côté loïc chesnais girard
président de la région bretagne a émis
le souhait que les bretons soient les
premiers en france à atteindre
l'immunité collective d'ici à la fin
août
la france devrait recevoir 23 million de
nouvelles doses de vaccins de précieux
sérum que l'on risque de s'arracher en
particulier dans les zones rurales ou
enclavées qui risquent d'être les
derniers servis